Do you ever feel like a fake? Like you're not really qualified for the job you're doing despite your achievements and credentials? Or like you've just lucked your way into whatever professional or academic success you enjoy, but you're just one mistake away from being found out for the fraud you really are. If so, you're not alone. Those are signs of imposter phenomenon, also called imposter syndrome. While estimates vary, some research suggests that up to 70% or more of people experience imposter feelings at some point in their lives. So where do these feelings come from?
你是否曾觉得自己是个冒牌货？尽管你取得了各种成就和资历，但你总觉得自己并不真正胜任目前的工作？或者觉得你只是靠运气才取得了现在的职业或学术成就，只要犯一个错误，就会被戳穿你其实是个骗子？如果这样，你并不孤单。这些都是“冒牌者现象”（imposter phenomenon，又称“冒牌者综合征”）的征兆。虽然估计数据有所不同，但一些研究表明，多达70%甚至更多的人在人生的某个阶段都曾体验过这种冒牌心理。那么，这些感受究竟从何而来？
Who is most likely to experience imposter phenomenon? What repercussions can it have in people's personal and professional lives? And if you're troubled by imposter feelings, what can you do to address them and keep them from holding you back? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills.
什么样的人最容易经历“冒牌者现象”？它会在人们的个人和职业生活中产生什么影响？如果你正为这种冒牌心理而困扰，你可以做些甚么来应对它们，并防止它们拖你的后腿？欢迎收听美国心理学会的旗舰播客《心理学畅谈》（Speaking of Psychology），该播客探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是主持人金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。
We have two guests today. First is Dr. Lisa Orbei Austin, a counseling psychologist and career coach in New York City, where she focuses on helping clients with career advancement, career transitions, and leadership development. Her book, Own Your Greatness, Overcome Imposter Syndrome, Beat Self-Doubt, and Succeed in Life, offers readers' advice based on decades of research, as well as her own experience, helping clients recognize and overcome imposter phenomenon. Our second guest is Dr. Kevin Coakley, a professor of educational psychology at the University of Tech, at Austin. Dr. Coakley studies African-American psychology, and he is particularly interested in
今天我们请到了两位嘉宾。首先是丽莎·奥尔比·奥斯汀（Lisa Orbe-Austin）博士，她是一位来自纽约市的咨询心理学家和职业教练，专注于帮助客户实现职业发展、职业转型和领导力培养。她的书《主宰你的伟大：克服冒牌者综合征，战胜自我怀疑，在生活中取得成功》（Own Your Greatness, Overcome Imposter Syndrome, Beat Self-Doubt, and Succeed in Life）为读者提供了基于数十年研究的建议，以及她本人帮助客户识别和克服“冒牌者现象”的经验。我们的第二位嘉宾是凯文·科克利（Kevin Coakley）博士，他是德克萨斯大学奥斯汀分校的教育心理学教授。科克利博士研究非裔美国人心理学，他特别感兴趣的是
understanding the psychological and environmental factors that affect African-American student achievement. As part of that work, he has explored the imposter phenomenon and its relationship to mental health and academic outcomes among ethnic minority students. Thank you both for joining me today. Thank you. Thank you for having us, Kim. Let's start briefly by talking about the words we're going to use. in the introduction a moment ago, I used the term imposter phenomenon, but many of our listeners may be more familiar with the term imposter syndrome. Are these just two different names for the same thing? In my own language, I use the language of the imposter phenomenon, which of course is the language that was used by Pauline Clance and Suzanne Iams when they introduced
了解影响非裔美国学生学业成就的心理和环境因素。作为这项工作的一部分，他探讨了“冒牌者现象”及其与少数族裔学生的心理健康和学业成果之间的关系。非常感谢两位今天做客节目。谢谢。谢谢邀请我们，金。让我们简短地从我们将要使用的词汇开始谈起。刚才在引言中，我使用了“冒牌者现象”这个词，但我们的许多听众可能对“冒牌者综合征”这个词更熟悉。这只是同一事物的两个不同名称吗？在我自己的语言中，我使用的是“冒牌者现象”这一术语，当然，这也是波琳·克兰斯（Pauline Clance）和苏珊·艾姆斯（Suzanne Imes）在提出
terminology to the literature. We see in sort of popular discourse now the words, the imposter syndrome, which is more popular than the phrase imposter phenomenon. I tend to stay away from the imposter syndrome because of the word syndrome itself has such a clinical sort of orientation and innuendo, and it was not, again, it is not a syndrome in a classic sense of something that is diagnosable the way that we think about sort of diagnosis as psychologists. So I tend to use the word imposter phenomenon, but I recognize that in terms of popular discourse, the phrase imposter syndrome is much more known. Yeah, and I agree with Kevin. In essence, in the book, I sort of talk about the fact that, you know, it is initially coined as imposter phenomenon,
这一术语时所使用的语言。我们现在看到大众话语中使用的是“冒牌者综合征”这个词，它比“冒牌者现象”这个词更受欢迎。我倾向于避开“冒牌者综合征”，因为“综合征”这个词本身具有强烈的临床导向和暗示，它并不是——再说一次，它不是传统意义上可以像我们心理学家那样进行诊断的综合征。所以我倾向于使用“冒牌者现象”这个词，但我承认，就大众话语而言，“冒牌者综合征”这个短语更为人所知。是的，我同意凯文的看法。本质上，我在书中谈到了这样一个事实，你知道的，它最初被创造为“冒牌者现象”，
doctors, clans and Ims, the originators of the concept, were very clear and never using the word syndrome and not wanting to go in that direction because of the medicalized and pathologizing kind of connotation to it. However, in my work, I often use syndrome because that's how people in popular culture identify it and don't identify it with phenomenon. And so it's easier for people to kind of search and find and connect to the idea. But in terms of it is fairly interchangeable, but I completely agree with Kevin around the concept. So as you said, there's no official diagnosis of imposter phenomenon. It's not in the diagnostic and statistical manual. It's not in the ICD, the international classifications
医生克兰斯和艾姆斯是这一概念的鼻祖，他们非常明确地从不使用“综合征”这个词，也不想朝那个方向发展，因为这带有医疗化和病理化的内涵。然而，在我的工作中，我经常使用“综合征”，因为这是大众文化中人们识别它的方式，而不是通过“现象”来识别。因此，人们更容易搜索、找到并连接到这个概念。但在本质上，它们是可以互换的，不过我完全同意凯文对这个概念的看法。正如你所说，“冒牌者现象”并没有官方诊断。它不在《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》中，也不在国际疾病分类（ICD）中。
of disease. Do either of you believe that it should be a form? normal diagnosis? And if so, would that be helpful or harmful? Well, I, again, I don't think that there should be a former diagnosis. I agree with Dr. Orbae-Austen that that in some ways sort of medicalizes and pathologizes a term that is really rooted in many ways to reactions to external social stimuli. And so I think that to suggest that it be sort of a former diagnosis really is misplaced and does a disservice to, you know, not recognizing the external environments and the other sort of stimuli that really are imposing upon people that help sort of exacerbate their feelings of imposterism. Yeah, I agree. I think
你们俩是否认为它应该成为一种正式诊断？如果是的话，这会有帮助还是会有害？嗯，再次强调，我认为不应该将其作为正式诊断。我同意奥尔比·奥斯汀博士的看法，在某种程度上，这会将一个实际上在很大程度上植根于对外部社会刺激反应的术语进行医疗化和病理化。因此，我认为建议将其作为正式诊断真的放错了重点，也无助于（你知道的）认识到外部环境以及其他强加在人们身上、加剧其冒牌心理感受的刺激因素。是的，我同意。我认为
there are many correlates of imposter syndrome to mental health issues. So, you know, people often have higher levels of anxiety or depression. There are other, like, really diagnostic conditions that do result from the experience. But the experience, I think, of it in and of itself probably doesn't require that. And I think, you know, if you think about diagnostic conditions and this idea that it's sort of impacting your social, relational, academic functioning, a lot of people with imposter syndrome are actually doing quite well. And so, yes, there are internal, you know, potential correlates, but not for everyone. And it sort of, it varies. And so I think it's really not necessarily, it doesn't necessarily have to be a diagnostic condition to receive intervention, support, you know,
“冒牌者综合征”与心理健康问题有很多相关性。所以，你知道的，人们往往会有更高水平的焦虑或抑郁。还有其他一些确实由这种经历导致的真正诊断性疾病。但我认为，这种经历本身可能不需要这种诊断。而且我认为，如果你考虑诊断性疾病以及它正在影响你的社会、人际、学业功能的这种观点，许多患有“冒牌者综合征”的人实际上过得相当好。所以，是的，存在内部的、潜在的相关性，但并非对每个人都如此。而且它是因人而异的。因此我认为它不一定非要成为一个诊断性疾病才能接受干涉、支持、或者你知道的
other things, be able to see it as a valid experience. Given the amount of coverage that, um, the phenomenon has had in the mainstream media, I think many people's general impression is that imposter phenomenon is a bigger problem for women. Does the research bear that out? Dr. Orbe Austin is, could you answer that? Who is most likely to experience imposter phenomena, imposter feelings? Well, I think like, I'll also ask Kevin for his opinion, Dr. Coagley's for his opinion, but in my understanding of the research, I feel like there hasn't been a conclusive point on whether or not one gender experiences it more than another. There isn't conclusive research to suggest, yes, women experience it more than others.
其他帮助，也能够被视为一种有效的经历。鉴于主流媒体对这种现象的报道量，我认为许多人的总体印象是，“冒牌者现象”对女性来说是一个更大的问题。研究是否证实了这一点？奥尔比·奥斯汀博士，你能回答一下吗？谁最容易经历“冒牌者现象”、冒牌感受？嗯，我想，我也想问问凯文的意见，也就是科克利博士的意见，但在我对研究的理解中，我觉得关于某个性别是否比另一个性别经历得更多，并没有一个确凿的结论。没有确凿的研究表明，是的，女性比其他人经历得更多。
I think because it was initially studied with women, I think people then feel like, oh, this is a women's issue. And I think, you know, some of the research shows that men experience it somewhat differently. And there's a lot of room for discussion around gender diversity and gender expression. We don't have a lot of research around that itself. But I think it's really important to note that sometimes men experience this in what looks like a different way. And so I think it oftentimes then goes a little bit under-reported in terms of their experience of it. Is sexism a factor here? I mean, is it just the fact that women often feel like we have to perform so much better than men?
我认为，由于它最初是在女性身上进行研究的，人们就会觉得，哦，这是一个女性的问题。而且我认为，有些研究表明男性的体验有些不同。并且，围绕性别多样性和性别表达还有很大的讨论空间。我们本身并没有这方面的大量研究。但我认为非常重要的一点是，有时男性以一种看起来不同的方式体验这一点。因此我认为，在他们的体验方面，往往会被稍微低估。性别歧视是其中的一个因素吗？我的意思是，这是否只是因为女性经常觉得我们必须比男性表现得好得多？
You know, Fred Astaire did, he was phenomenal, but, you know, his partner danced backwards in high heels. I mean, you always have to be a little bit better than Ginger Rogers. I lost her name for a minute. Is that part of why women may feel it more acutely? And even Dr. Coakley, ethnic minorities, I mean, the same thing. you know, you have to, because you study that area, you have to perform that much higher a level in order to be taken seriously in many situations. Yeah, no, I would agree with what Dr. Orbe also said, that in the original context,
你知道的，弗雷德·阿斯泰尔（Fred Astaire）很了不起，但是，你知道的，他的舞伴穿着高跟鞋倒着跳舞。我的意思是，你总是必须比金格·罗杰斯（Ginger Rogers）优秀一点。我一会儿忘了她的名字。这是否是女性可能更强烈地感受到它的部分原因？甚至对于科克利博士来说，少数族裔也是如此，我的意思是，同样的事情。你知道的，因为你研究这个领域，在很多情况下，你必须表现出更高的水平才能被认真对待。是的，不，我同意奥尔比·奥斯汀博士刚才所说的，在最初的语境中，
the focus was on women and women who were, you know, very successful. And I think that Dr. Clancy and Dr. Aimes perhaps thought that it was, you know, more salient with women. but the research itself has been equivocal. In my own research, I have conducted studies where some studies, women have reported higher imposter feelings, but in other studies, there's not been any significant sex difference at all.
重点是女性以及那些非常成功的女性。我认为克兰斯博士和艾姆斯博士可能认为这在女性中更为突出。但研究本身一直是模棱两可的。在我自己的研究中，我进行过这样的研究：在一些研究中，女性报告了更高的冒牌感受，但在其他研究中，根本没有出现显著的性别差异。
And that's the case with other studies that have reported on imposter phenomenon of finding. So the findings are equivocal. What I will say, and I agree again with Dr. Orby-A-A-Lson, that you do see that the way that imposter feelings manifest themselves takes on a very gendered sort of approach. So, for example, I have found in one of my studies,
其他报告“冒牌者现象”发现的研究也是如此。因此，研究结果是模棱两可的。我要说的是，我再次同意奥尔比·奥斯汀博士的观点，你会发现“冒牌者感受”表现出来的方式确实带有一种非常性别化的方法。例如，我在我的一项研究中发现，
looking at academic outcomes, that imposter feelings were much more salient for women concerning GPA compared to men. There was no significant mean difference. They both reported similar levels of imposterism, but its implications for academic outcomes, in this case, GPA, was definitely gendered. And so that's the way that I think it's best to think about any sort of potential gender differences
在观察学业成果时，与男性相比，女性关于GPA的冒牌感受更为显著。两者的平均分没有显著差异。他们都报告了相似水平的冒牌心理，但它对学业成果（在此例中为GPA）的影响绝对是性别化的。因此，这就是我认为思考任何涉及冒牌感受的潜在性别差异的最佳方式。
involving imposter feelings. And then regarding ethnic minorities, absolutely, I became interested in the area because of my own research on the psychosocial experiences of African-recogn students and other BIPA students. And when I came across the imposterism literature, I was fascinated because there had been relatively little work done on students of color. And so I saw where it would be immediately. applicable to the work that I was doing. And it turns out that I was right because many, many BIPAC students report feelings of imposterism in predominantly white educational spaces. And so I think
然后关于少数族裔，绝对是这样，我之所以对这个领域感兴趣，是因为我对自己关于非裔学生和其他多元族裔（BIPAC）学生心理社会经历的研究。当我偶然读到关于冒牌心理的文献时，我着迷了，因为针对有色人种学生的研究相对较少。所以我看到它将直接适用于我正在做的工作。事实证明我是对的，因为许许多多的多元族裔学生在主要是白人的教育空间中都报告了冒牌心理。因此我认为
that there is definitely a very strong connection there. Yeah, and I think I'll add to that in the sense that we talk about this in our work and our training is about sort of the double impact of imposter syndrome for women, for people of color, of this experience of having these internal feelings, like, I might be a fraud. Like, I don't know if I belong here. I might be incompetent. And then this external communication happening from the world being like, Mill, maybe you don't belong here. Maybe you got here because of a diversity program. Maybe you're not good enough.
这里面绝对有着非常紧密的联系。是的，我想补充一点，我们在工作和培训中谈论过这一点，即女性和有色人种受到的“冒牌者综合征”的双重打击：这种拥有内心感受的经历，比如“我可能是个骗子”，“我不知道我是否属于这里”，“我可能不称职”；然后是来自外部世界的沟通反馈，比如，“米尔斯，也许你不属于这里，也许你是通过多元化项目才来到这里的，也许你还不够好”。
And so as you're working on it and trying to believe in your competence and skills, you're getting these external messages that are reinforcing the imposter syndrome, which I think makes it more difficult to overcome because you're getting these additional signals like, hey, maybe you are. And I think, you know, as a result of systems of oppression and other things, they kind of benefit from you maintaining your imposter syndrome. So, you know, I think it's really important to kind of recognize that it can be experienced very different in different populations.
因此，当你正在努力克服它并试图相信自己的能力和技能时，你正在收到这些强化“冒牌者综合征”的外部信息，我认为这使得它更难克服，因为你不断收到这些额外的信号，比如，“嘿，也许你真的是”。并且我认为，由于压迫系统和其他因素的结果，它们在某种程度上受益于你保持“冒牌者综合征”。所以，你知道的，我认为非常重要的一点是要认识到，它在不同人群中的体验可以非常不同。
Well, let's talk for a minute about how imposter feelings affect people's lives. Dr. Orbea Austin, how do you see it affecting your clients in terms of their career paths and the career choices that they make? Well, I mean, I think it's interesting because I think many of them, I deal with mostly, I work a lot with women. And I think many of them, you know, what the literature finds around women and some of the ways in which they deal with it is that they're counterphobic, and so they actually face the thing that they're afraid of, and so I don't see them not achieving. I do see them struggling to advocate for themselves
好吧，让我们花一点时间讨论一下冒牌感受是如何影响人们的生活的。奥尔比·奥斯汀博士，您如何看待它在职业道路和所做职业选择方面对您的客户产生的影响？嗯，我的意思是，我认为这很有趣，因为我认为他们中的许多人——我主要打交道的人群中，我有很多客户是女性。并且我认为她们中的许多人，正如文献发现的关于女性以及她们应对该问题的一些方式那样，她们具有反势力恐怖症（counterphobic），所以她们实际上会直面她们害怕的事物，所以我没有看到她们不去取得成就。我看到她们在为自己争取权益时在苦苦挣扎
in terms of salary, to sometimes feel like they can find other opportunities elsewhere, feeling like maybe this is the only place that will really appreciate me and sort of getting stuck in places. I find they often struggle with advocating for promotion and other things. And also, too, I think also in management, struggle with delegation and micromanaging. feeling like their direct reports are a direct reflection on them and they don't want to be exposed. And so I do see it come up in these different ways. Dr. Coakley, how does it affect achievement and mental health in the students you've studied? Well, it's interesting because with students of color, I see them really sometimes struggling with
在薪酬方面，有时候觉得她们无法在其他地方找到其他机会，觉得也许这里是唯一真正欣赏我的地方，从而陷入某些地方无法自拔。我发现她们经常在争取晋升和其他事情上挣扎。此外，我认为在管理方面，在授权和微观管理方面也很挣扎。觉得她们直接管理的下属是她们自己的直接反映，她们不想被暴露。所以我确实看到它以这些不同的方式出现。科克利博士，它如何影响您所研究的学生的成就和心理健康？嗯，这很有趣，因为对于有色人种学生，我看到他们有时确实在苦苦挣扎
acknowledging to other people that they have these feelings. So what ends up happening is, is that BIPOC students in predominantly white spaces are well aware of the perception that they, by son, that they don't belong there, that they're simply there because of affirmative action. And so they want to sort of prove to others and to themselves that though I belong here because of my achievements and because I am meritorious,
向其他人承认他们有这种感受。所以最终发生的情况是，多元族裔学生在主要是白人的空间里，非常清楚地意识到这样一种看法：由他们自己感知到的，他们不属于这里，他们来这里只是因为平权行动（affirmative action）。所以他们想要向别人和自己证明，尽管我属于这里是因为我的成就，因为我有功绩，
but yet they still have this little voice that says, you know, maybe you really were just simply a product of affirmative action. And so this causes, In addition to all the other sort of stressors that all college students experience, this added sort of what I call this sort of like racialized expression of imposterism is an additional burden and stress on students of color, which ends up sort of taking a toll on them emotionally and their well-being. Now, I will say this, that it's interesting because when you look at, and there's not a lot of empirical data right now that supports this, but when you look at the sort of effect on the actual achievement, you'll see that in some cases, I mean, this is perhaps more anecdotal than supported by data, but it seems that individuals who have imposter feelings are also performing in some cases at even higher levels.
但他们内心深处仍然有一个小小的声音在说：“你知道的，也许你真的只是平权行动的产物。”因此，除了所有大学生都经历的所有其他压力源之外，这种我称之为“种族化表现”的额外压力，对有色人种学生来说是一种额外的负担和压力，最终在情绪和福祉上对他们造成了损害。现在，我要说的是，这很有趣，因为当你观察时——目前没有太多的实证数据支持这一点——但当你观察对实际成就的某种影响时，你会发现在某些情况下，我的意思是，这可能比数据支持的更多是轶事证据，但似乎拥有冒牌感受的个人在某些情况下甚至表现出更高的水平。
In other words, they work so hard to try to sort of counter any sort of perceptions that they don't belong there, that they might end up doing, you know, relatively well, but suffer from sort of, you know, mental health sort of challenges. And so certainly I see, you know, with students of color, them also sort of overachieving, overperforming, trying to sort of counter what they believe to be perceptions about their worthiness of being there. So they might, on the one hand, look, you know, pretty good on paper in terms of their academic achievements, but they may be suffering from mental health decline. You've both written about your personal experiences with imposter phenomenon. Can you talk about those a little bit, how those experiences have informed the work that you.
换句话说，他们非常努力地工作，试图以此来反驳任何认为他们不属于这里的看法，以至于他们最终可能会做得相对较好，但却饱受某种心理健康挑战之苦。因此，我当然看到，你知道的，对于有色人种学生来说，他们也有点过度成就、过度表现，试图反驳他们认为是关于他们是否有资格留在那里的看法。所以他们一方面在纸面上看起来相当不错，就他们的学业成就而言，但他们可能正在遭受心理健康状况下降的折磨。你们俩都写过关于自己经历“冒牌者现象”的个人经历。你们能稍微谈谈这些吗？这些经历是如何为你们的工作提供参考的？
you do. I mean, for me, it's what drew me to the work, actually, is my own personal experience with imposter syndrome. I probably had a very different research path early on, and I think, and writing path. But I think that, you know, having experienced it very, very, like, pretty impactfully, like I, I mean, I talk about in a TEDx talk and I was in a particularly bad job after I graduated from my PhD program, and I was working for a pretty oppressive boss and felt stuck. I felt stuck in a very, really, I felt like stuck in a way I couldn't apply for other jobs. I couldn't talk to people. I was really, really stuck in this job where he was really just making sure that I didn't go anywhere else. He wasn't necessarily ever complimenting me or ever saying
确实如此。我的意思是，对我来说，正是由于我自己对冒名顶替综合征的亲身经历，才吸引我从事这项研究。早期我的研究路径可能非常不同，写作路径也是如此。但我认为，你知道，经历过非常深刻的这种冲击之后——比如我在TEDx演讲中讲过，我从博士项目毕业后曾在一份特别糟糕的工作中工作，我为一位相当压迫的老板效力，感到被困住了。我感到自己被困在了一种无法申请其他工作、无法与人交流的境地。我真的、真的很深陷于这份工作中，而他其实只是在确保我不会去任何其他地方。他从不夸奖我，也从不说
I did a good job, but making sure that I felt really underwater. And it wasn't until I was in a meeting and I show this often that I was in a meeting. It was an all-female senior staff and there was music playing in the background and someone said, what is this music that's playing? And he said, it's music to soothe the savage breast. And in that one moment, I sort of like woke up and I was like, what am I doing to myself? And why am I here and why am I putting up with this? And I, and it was all the imposter stuff. I didn't feel good enough. I didn't feel worthy. I didn't feel like I deserved anything. I didn't, you know, and I just really decided I didn't want to live like that anymore. And I actually quit the job on, on that Monday and left and started my practice. And, and, and, I
我干得好，而是确保我感到自己如履薄冰。直到有一次开会时——我经常讲起这个——那是一次全由女性组成的高管会议，背景放着音乐，有人问：“这放的是什么音乐？”他回答说：“这是抚慰凶猛野兽的音乐。”就在那一瞬间，我仿佛惊醒了，心想：“我对自己在做什么？我为什么会在这里？我为什么要忍受这一切？”所有的冒名顶替情绪都涌上心头。我觉得自己不够好，觉得自己不配拥有这一切，觉得自己不配得到任何东西。你知道的，我真的下定决心再也不想那样生活了。于是我实际上在那个星期一就辞职了，离开了那里，并开始了自己的开业执业，而且，而且，我
like soon after and finally took my licensing exam, did all the things that I was actually not executing on it that were related to my dreams and my goals and my wishes. So for me, like the way it connects for me is that, you know, I feel a very distinct passion for making other people aware of how it operates in their lives and helping them, you know, be free of it so that they can feel like they can live in their dreams and not feel the oppression of it. And I think, you know, like Kevin was mentioning, I think from an external level, I don't think anyone would be looking at my career going, God, that's a disaster. But for me, it felt like that's what was happening. And I wasn't living in the things that I wanted to be doing for myself. And so that's how it connects
不久后就参加并考过了行医执照考试，做了所有我以前没有执行的、与我的梦想、目标和愿望相关的事情。所以对我和我的联系方式来说，你知道，我对让其他人意识到它如何在他们的生活中运作产生了非常强烈的热情，并帮助他们摆脱它，这样他们就能觉得他们可以活在自己的梦想中，而不必感受到它的压迫。我认为，正如凯文所提到的，从外在层面上看，我认为不会有人看着我的职业生涯说“天哪，那真是一场灾难”。但对当时的我觉得事情就是这样发生着的。我没有过上自己想要的生活。这就是它与我的联系
for me. Dr. Coakley, what about you? Well, you know, it's interesting. When I give talks to students about my own path to sort of where I've gotten professionally, I always share with them the stories of some of my struggles as an undergraduate student and how, you know, I, you know, had an scholarship. I was immediately placed on academic probation after my first semester in college. And so I talk about sort of how I struggle, you know, as a student academically. And then sort of when students sort of see where I am now and professionally, they're always amazed. But what, where it is relevant for me even today is that in spite of all of the accolades and things that I've been able to accomplished in my career, I still harbor vestiges of imposterism. And it may seem crazy because,
科克利博士，你呢？嗯，你知道，这很有趣。当我给学生们做关于我如何走到今天这个职业地位的心路历程的演讲时，我总是与他们分享我作为本科生时的一些挣扎故事，以及我是如何获得奖学金的，但在大学第一个学期后我立刻就被留校察看了。因此，我谈到了我作为一名学生在学业上面临的挣扎。然后当学生们看到我现在的专业地位时，他们总是感到惊讶。但它对今天的我仍然具有现实意义的地方在于，尽管我在职业生涯中获得了所有的荣誉和成就，我内心深处依然潜藏着冒名顶替感的残余。这看起来可能很疯狂，因为
you know, I've, you know, I've done pretty well as an academic. And yet I still sometimes look at myself and think, you know, are you really all that your accolades would suggest that you are? I mean, it's crazy. I honestly still struggle with that at times. It's so not crazy, Kevin. I mean, I was having imposter feelings. last night because I was going to be on this podcast with you. And I was like, oh my God, what do I know about imposter syndrome? It's Dr. Copley. Yeah, no, it's real. It is very real. Well, so that raises a question of whether imposter phenomenon can ever have any positive effects. I mean, does it spur people to excel? I think you talked about that a little bit.
你知道，我在学术界其实做得挺不错的。然而，有时我看着自己还是会想：“你真的配得上你所拥有的那些荣誉吗？”我的意思是，这太疯狂了。老实说，我有时仍然在为此苦恼。一点也不疯狂，凯文。我是说，昨晚我还感受到了冒名顶替的情绪，因为我要和你在同一个播客里。当时我想：“天哪，我对冒名顶替综合征了解多少？那是科克利博士啊。”是的，不，这是真实的。这非常真实。那么，这就引发了一个问题：冒名顶替现象是否能带来任何积极的影响？我的意思是，它会促使人变得卓越吗？我想你之前稍微谈到过这一点。
Yeah, no, it does. I mean, I think that, you know, so for example, when I describe what has what has been documented as the imposter cycle, you'll see that people sort of take these sort of two paths, those one of over-preparation and one of procrastination. For me, it's the path of over-preparation. So when I'm, for example, giving a talk on the imposter feelings, I prepare as though I've never given the talk before. Like, I, as though I haven't given dozens and dozens and dozens of the talk so much so that my partner says to me, Kevin, why are you spending so much time preparing? Like, you know this like the back of your hand. Yes, I do. But I, but I, I, I never want people to sort of hear me and think he does not know what he's talking about.
对，不，确实会。我的意思是，如果你看看我所描述的、已被文献证实的“冒名顶替循环”，你会发现人们通常会走两条路径之一：一条是过度准备，另一条是拖延。对我来说，我走的是过度准备这条路。所以，举个例子，当我要做一个关于冒名顶替情绪的演讲时，我会像自己从未做过这个演讲一样去准备。就好像我没有做过几十次、上百次这个演讲一样，以至于我的伴侣对我说：“凯文，你为什么花这么多时间和精力在准备上？这东西你早就烂熟于心了。”是的，我是知道。但是，但是，我永远不希望人们听我说话时觉得他其实根本不知道自己在说什么。
So I really overprepared. And so I think what happens with people who experience imposterism is that they will sort of go to extra mile. They will work extra hard to try to, you know, sort of do well whatever the task is. And so I think in that sense it can have a positive effect. But again, I want to make sure that you understand that oftentimes is coupled with, you know, the negative impact that it has on one sort of well-being. Yeah.
所以我真的准备过度了。因此，我认为经历冒名顶替感的人往往会付出额外的努力。为了把不管什么任务做好，他们会格外努力地工作。所以从这个意义上说，它可能会产生积极的影响。但同样地，我想确保你明白，这通常与它对一个人福祉产生的负面影响交织在一起。是的。
I mean, I think it's a great point. Like, there's always, like, as I'm sort of in recovery of my own imposterous. I'm always working to check myself around the overwork and over-functioning that has done me well. And, you know, I went to an Ivy League call. You know, like, I did all this things. But I think that it has had such negative other aspects that I've come to recognize that I can be successful without thinking that everyone's going to think I'm a fraud.
我的意思是，我觉得这是一个很好的观点。就像，总会有这样的情况——当我正在从自己的冒名顶替状态中恢复时——我总是在努力监督自己，克制那种让我受益匪浅的过度工作和过度运转。而且，你知道，我上的是常春藤盟校，你知道的，我做了所有这些事情。但我认为它带来了如此多的负面影响，以至于我开始认识到，即使不认为每个人都觉得我是个骗子，我也能够获得成功。
And that those skills still exist within me, whether I think I'm a, fraud or not, and then I think it's so much better if I just proceed forward as if I'm not a fraud, because I think it'll be better for me a long term. And it reminds me of something my husband said to me when I was trying to break out of my imposter syndrome, and he said, like, if you work as hard for yourself as you do for others, you're going to be unstoppable. And part of my work was around really learning how to work in that effort for myself, as opposed for proving myself, as opposed to making people like me and all this other stuff. And I did it because of things I was invested in,
并且，无论我觉得自己是不是骗子，那些技能依然存在于我体内。而且我认为，如果我直接假装自己不是骗子那样去行事，效果会好得多，因为我认为长远来看这对我有好处。这让我想起我丈夫对我说过的一句话，当时我正试图摆脱冒名顶替综合征，他说：“如果你为自己工作就像为别人工作那样努力，你将势不可挡。”我的部分工作就在于真正学会为自己付出这种努力，而不是为了证明自己，而不是为了讨好别人以及所有这些其他的事情。我这样做是因为我投入其中的事情，
I was interested in that I wanted to do. I think it was a much better investment of my energy in that direction. But it's a constant battle. How is this different from just being an overachiever? Because it sounds like that's what you're describing, except that maybe you feel like there's somebody at your back, who's chasing you or criticizing you. Well, I mean, I think there's certainly a lot of overlap.
是我感兴趣的、我想去做的事情。我认为朝这个方向投入精力是一个更好的投资。但这这是一场持续的战斗。这与单纯的“过度成就者”有什么不同？因为听起来你描述的就是那种状态，只不过可能你觉得背后有个人在追赶你或批评你。嗯，我的意思是，这两者之间肯定有很多重叠。
I mean, being an overachiever, and in fact, what you'll see, for example, one of the studies that I conducted, perfectionism has been oftentimes linked to feelings of imposterism. And that's absolutely the case that individuals who have imposterous feelings oftentimes will find themselves to be sort of perfectionist. And, of course, we know perfectionism, your perfectionism can be both adaptive and maladaptive. And it's the maladaptive forms of perfectionism that will result in sort of phyllis of imposterism being particularly harmful. And so certainly there's a strong sort of connection between sort of perfectionism and sort of, you know, these sort of feelings that we sometimes struggle with of imposterism. And I think it's such an interesting point because I think the other thing can happen,
我的意思是，作为一个过度成就者——事实上，你会发现，比如我进行的一项研究中，完美主义经常与冒名顶替感联系在一起。事实也确实如此，有冒名顶替感的人往往会发现自己也是完美主义者。当然，我们知道完美主义既可以是适应性的，也可以是适应不良的。正是那些适应不良的完美主义形式，才会导致冒名顶替感变得特别有害。因此，完美主义与我们有时与之苦恼的这种冒名顶替感之间，肯定存在着很强的联系。我认为这是一个非常有趣的观点，因为我认为另一件事也会发生，
which is true too, which is I see an underachievement as well because of the perfectionism. It's like if I can't do it perfectly, I'm not going to do it at all. because then it will expose me. And so I think you can see both the overachievement and you can see underachievement. And sometimes they're in different domains or in other areas. But I think it's such an important piece around the perfectionism and how it does underlie. It can make you a great success and it can make you a great failure. And I think it's really kind of how it sort of operates in your particular experience, you know.
这也是真的，那就是由于完美主义，我也看到了“低成就”现象。这就好像：如果我不能做得完美，那我就干脆不做。因为那样会暴露我的不足。因此，我认为你可以同时看到过度成就和低成就这两种表现。有时它们发生在不同的领域或其他方面。但我认为，围绕完美主义及其如何作为基础，这是一个非常重要的方面。它既能让你取得巨大的成功，也能让你遭遇惨败。我认为这真的取决于它如何在你的特定经历中发挥作用。
So it sounds like you both have techniques for dealing with this within yourselves. What kind of advice do you give to people who are experiencing imposter phenomenon that might be holding them back? Are there techniques that they can use? I've read, for example, that group therapy is one thing that might be helpful. What else can people do if they're having this experience? Well, I'll offer one that I sort of talk about. So part of what happens with individuals who experience apostatism is that they tend to discount the really positive things that they have achieved, all of their accomplishments. And so it's helpful if you make people or if you sort of ask people to really make a considered effort to attend to and to document
听起来你们两个都有应对自身这种状况的方法。对于那些正在经历冒名顶替现象并因此受阻的人，你们会给出什么建议？他们可以使用什么技巧吗？例如，我读过文章说团体治疗可能是有效的方法之一。如果人们正在经历这种状况，还能做些什么呢？好吧，我先分享一个我经常谈论的方法。经历冒名顶替综合征的人身上发生的一部分情况是，他们往往会贬低自己真正取得的积极成果以及所有的成就。因此，如果你让人们或者如果你引导人们刻意努力去关注并记录下来，这将非常有用
all those things that they actually have done well. So for example, if you say, look, consider keeping a weekly or biweekly sort of diary. Every time that you've done something well where you've been acknowledged, where you've done a very good job, acknowledge it, just sort of documented. And then sort of come back and review that because what ends up happening is you'll see, you know what I actually have done a very good job on you know fill in the blank on this test on this task on this you know sort of project because when you're suffering from imposterism it's it becomes very easy to minimize or to
所有他们实际上做得很的事情。例如，如果你说，看，考虑写一份每周或每两周一次的日记。每当你做好了某件事、得到了认可、干得非常出色时，就承认它，把它记录下来。然后回头去复盘，因为最终你会发现：“你知道吗，在这次测试中、在这项任务中、在这个项目中（填空处），我实际上真的干得很出色。”因为当你深受冒名顶替感折磨时，你很容易去忽视或
discount all those things you just don't even acknowledge or sometimes you just forget so so attending to those things and making a concerted effort to document them and to revisit them periodically to see hey you know what I have actually done you know better than what I give myself credit for for. Yeah, and I think, you know, my book is like all the interventions that have been in the literature and then and sort of also things that I've seen work in my practice. And I think the other, I would definitely agree with Dr. Cloakley on that. And I think in addition to like dealing with your automatic negative thoughts, you know, learning like that certain thoughts are triggered by
贬低所有这些事情，你甚至不去承认它们，有时你干脆就忘了。所以，关注这些事情，并刻意去记录它们，定期重新审视它们，看看：“嘿，你知道吗，我实际上做得比我自认为的要好。”是的，我认为，你知道，我的书里总结了文献中出现过的所有干预措施，以及我在实践中看到确实有效的方法。我认为另一个，我绝对同意科克利博士的看法。我认为除了处理你的自动消极思维之外——你知道，了解某些想法是被冒名顶替综合征触发的，
the imposter syndrome and how do you combat the automatic negative thought and don't just believe it and fall into the cycle of overworking or procrastinating. Working on yourself care, oftentimes when we have imposter syndrome, we put ourselves at the bottom of the list of who we care about or who we take care of, who we spend time on, really learning how to prioritize that, because one of the biggest outcomes from imposter genome is burnout. And so how do you help avoid chronic burnout? How do you deal with it? How do you recognize and structure self-care?
以及如何对抗自动消极思维，而不仅仅是相信它并陷入过度工作或拖延的循环中——还要致力于自我关怀。通常当我们有冒名顶替综合征时，我们会把自我关怀、关心自己、把时间花在自己身上排在心目中的最后一位。真正学会优先处理这件事，因为冒名顶替综合征最大的后果之一就是职业倦怠。那么，你如何帮助避免长期的职业倦怠？你如何应对它？你如何识别并构建自我关怀？
I think oftentimes also we're caught up in very rigid roles around our imposter syndrome. We know how to be the helper. We know how to be the go-to person. We know how to be certain things, but we don't know how to expand outside of those roles. So how do we learn how to ask for help? How do we learn how to widen our role sets? And also building community around this. We often struggle with this alone. And how do you build community around you that can support you as you kind of recover from this experience? So I think those are some of them I would also add. Is imposterism something that tends to affect younger people, college students especially, or is that just because that's the research that's out there right now? But by the time people are more established in their careers, does it taper off?
我认为很多时候，我们也陷入了围绕冒名顶替综合征的非常僵化的角色中。我们知道如何当好帮手，我们知道如何成为那个随叫随到的人，我们知道如何扮演某些特定的角色，但我们不知道如何跳出这些角色去拓展。那么，我们如何学会寻求帮助？我们如何学会拓宽我们的角色设定？还有围绕这一点建立社群。我们经常独自一人与此苦恼。你如何在你周围建立能够支持你的社群，从而帮助你从这段经历中恢复过来？所以我想这些也是我会补充的一些建议。冒名顶替感是一种往往会影响年轻人、尤其是大学生的现象吗？还是说这只是因为目前外界的研究恰好局限于此？等人们在职业生涯中更加稳定后，这种感觉会逐渐消退吗？
I mean, do you just grow and become more confident, or do you really have to keep working on it for your whole life? I mean, I think there are ways to kind of minimize it and to get, I always say, isn't it going to go away? Probably not. But can you turn the dial down on it so quietly that you can't even hear? it or barely hear it? Yes. And it depends on sort of your trigger and when you're getting triggered. But I would say like some of the early dates, there's some data out there that
我的意思是，随着你成长，你会变得更加自信吗？还是说你真的必须一辈子都在为此努力？我的意思是，我认为有一些方法可以将其最小化，并且我总是说：“难道它不会消失吗？”大概不会。但你能把它的音量调小到你甚至听不见，或者几乎听不见的程度吗？是的。这取决于你的触发点以及你何时被触发。但我想说，有些早期的数据显示
suggests that does not get better with time. There was a study by KPMG in 2020 that showed that female executives had a rate of 75% imposter syndrome. So that's higher number than we generally see. So part of the, I think part of the understanding of that is as we become more visible, have more responsibility, have more on the line. It can sometimes make. make our imposter syndrome worse because there's just a greater stakes at hand. If we lose this, it's a bigger deal. So it can be exacerbated over time depending on responsibility. But I don't know if there are cohort effects. But I definitely, I'm very interested in sort of more research in the field of imposter syndrome. Yeah, no, I would agree with what Dr. Orby also said. I'm not aware of any
它不会随着时间的推移而改善。毕马威（KPMG）在2020年的一项研究表明，女性高管的冒名顶替综合征发生率高达75%。这个数字比我们通常看到的要高。因此，我认为对这一现象的部分理解在于：随着我们变得更加引人注目、承担更多责任、面临更多利害关系，它有时会让我们的冒名顶替综合征变得更严重，因为眼下的风险更大了。如果我们失去这一切，事情就大条了。因此，根据责任的不同，它可能会随着时间推移而加剧。我不知道是否存在世代效应。但我绝对非常关注冒名顶替综合征领域的更多研究。是的，不，我也同意奥比-奥斯汀博士所说的话。我不知道有任何
research that has examined cohort effects. But as I sort of shared anecdotally, you know, I, you know, I'm a 50 year old man who's, you know, reason to be successful in my profession and still have had, you know, experiences where I struggle with imposterism. So I would just sort of say that there's probably not a lot of data that would suggest that there are, you know, sort of these profound sort of age differences, although there may be. I'm just, I'm not aware of any research. But I would agree with Dr. Orby Austin that I think that people can certainly learn to sort of dial down those imposter feelings with sort of age and experience and maturity. At least we hope that that's the case. So what is the relationship between imposter phenomenon and other mental
研究考察过世代效应。但正如我之前以个人经历为例所分享的那样，我是一个50岁的男人，在我的职业生涯中取得了合理的成功，却仍然经历过与冒名顶替感挣扎的时刻。所以我只想说，可能并没有太多数据表明存在这种深刻的年龄差异，尽管可能确实存在。我只是不知道有这样的研究。但我同意奥比-奥斯汀博士的看法，我认为人们随着年龄、经验和成熟度，肯定能学会把那些冒名顶替的感觉调小。至少我们希望如此。那么，冒名顶替现象与你刚才提到的其他心理健康挑战（比如焦虑或抑郁）之间有什么关系呢？
health challenges that you mentioned earlier like anxiety or depression? Well, I mean, the relationship is that there has been a consistent finding that imposter feelings are associated with increased feelings of anxiety or symptoms of anxiety and depression. I mean, every study that I've ever conducted in every study that I've ever seen reported shows this association. So, yeah, I mean, I think that's, I think we're pretty confident to saying that if you are experiencing, you know, imposterism, you are likely going to be also experiencing feelings of, you know, symptoms of anxiety and some depression. And so if you treat those symptoms, then does that help the imposter phenomenon? Not necessarily. They can be different, right? I think, you know, one of the
嗯，我的意思是，它们之间的关系在于，研究一直发现冒名顶替感与焦虑或焦虑抑郁症状的增加有关。我的意思是，我做过的每一项研究以及我见过的每一项报告的研究都显示了这种关联。所以，是的，我认为我们可以很有把握地说，如果你正在经历冒名顶替感，你也很可能会同时体验到焦虑和一些抑郁的症状。那么，如果你治疗了这些症状，这会有助于缓解冒名顶替现象吗？不一定。它们可以是不同的，对吧？我认为，你知道，其中
things that I've seen, though, is people who have treated their, you know, anxiety with, like, CBT skills or can use some of the similar CBT skills around their imposter syndrome. So I think you can, the skills that you're learning are transferable, but I think you have to tackle the specific, you know, experiences of imposter syndrome around this experience of being a fraud and it being competent. One of the things that I think is really important for me and my work has been to help people to identify the early experiences that were the foundation for work. why this imposter syndrome became what it became, whether it was rigid roles in childhood, or whether it was family dynamics that were common.
我见过的一件事是，那些用CBT（认知行为疗法）技能治疗过焦虑症的人，可以围绕他们的冒名顶替综合征使用一些类似的CBT技能。所以我认为，你正在学习的技能是可以迁移的，但我认为你必须针对冒名顶替综合征的具体体验进行处理，特别是那种觉得自己是个骗子、觉得自己不称职的体验。在我看来，对我以及我的工作非常重要的一件事情是，帮助人们识别那些作为根基的早期经历——为什么这个冒名顶替综合征会演变成现在这样，无论是童年时僵化的角色，还是常见的家庭动力关系。
I think that has been really helpful for people because I think they start to realize, oh, this thing didn't come from nowhere. And the reason why I'm triggered by particular things today has a history, and that makes sense to me, as opposed to this thing came out of nowhere, and now I don't know how to stop it. I think it gives people agency in a sense of like, oh, I get it now. this didn't come from absolutely nowhere. Yeah, no, if I could build on that, I mean, when you read, you know, some of the early work by Clance and Iams,
我认为这对大家真的很有帮助，因为他们开始意识到，哦，原来这东西并不是凭空出现的。今天我对某些特定事情产生触发是有历史原因的，这对我来说就说得通了，而不是觉得这东西莫名其妙地出现，现在我却不知道该怎么阻止它。在某种意义上，这赋予了人们一种掌控感，就像是，哦，我明白了，这绝对不是凭空而来的。是的，没错，如果我能在此基础上继续说的话，我的意思是，当你阅读克兰斯和伊姆斯的一些早期著作时，
they talk about both having internal factors and the external environment sort of factors in terms of contributing to how the impulsive phenomenon was created. So, for example, regarding internal factors, what they noticed amongst the women that they were working with was the women reported receiving messages about being competent in all these different areas. you're so skilled interpersonally, you're so skilled, I mean, in all these other areas, but not anything related to their intelligence. So they started to at some point think, well, I'm good in these other ways that are more sort of socially related, but no one is ever telling me that I'm, you know, naturally intelligent or that I'm intelligent. So they started to internalize those messages.
他们谈到了内部因素和外部环境因素如何共同作用，从而促成了这种冒名顶替现象的产生。例如，关于内部因素，他们注意到在与之合作的女性中，这些女性报告说她们收到了关于自己在各个不同领域都很有能力的讯息：你在人际交往中如此娴熟，你在所有这些其他领域都如此娴熟，但却没有收到任何与她们的智力相关的讯息。因此，她们在某个时候开始心想，嗯，我在这些更偏向社交的方面表现不错，但从来没有人告诉我，你知道的，我是天生聪明的，或者我是聪明的。于是她们开始内化这些讯息。
And then in terms of the external environment, being told, for example, that they, in fact, were really smart, very competent, superior even. but then finding that even though I'm being told this, I'm struggling to meet these expectations. I'm trying to sort of live up to what people are saying that I am, but not being able to or feeling like they're not being able to. And so both those sort of internal factors in the external environment were reported by Clance and Iams as sort of contributing to the creation of imposter feelings. What is the role of institutions and leaders like professors or managers to address imposter syndrome? We've been talking a fair amount about what individuals can do themselves, but is there something that institutions, companies can do to recognize and help people address it?
至于外部环境，例如被告知她们实际上真的很聪明、非常有能力、甚至是优秀的，但随后却发现，尽管别人这么对我说，我却在努力达到这些期望。我试图去符合别人对我的看法，却做不到，或者觉得自己做不到。因此，克兰斯和伊姆斯指出，这些内部因素和外部环境共同促成了冒名顶替感的产生。机构和领导者（如教授或经理）在解决冒名顶替综合征方面扮演什么角色？我们已经花了不少时间讨论个人自己能做些什么，但机构和公司是否可以做些什么来认可并帮助人们解决这个问题呢？
Where do I get started on this? I think, you know, companies benefit from this, right? Because if you are overfunctioning and overworking and overperforming, they're benefiting, they're in essence sometimes getting two or three people for the price of one. And so I do think it is there's a lot of inside the system that, that is, encourages this level of impossible. I actually was doing a training recently, and someone was saying, look, I'm working on trying to have more balance in my life, and I want to do an adequate job. And I ask my manager, can I just do an adequate job and not do exceeds expectations?
我该从哪里说起呢？我认为，公司其实从中受益，对吧？因为如果你过度运转、过度工作、过度表现，他们正在从中受益，他们有时实质上是用一个人的薪水得到了两三个人的产出。因此，我确实认为系统内部有很多东西在鼓励这种不可能的高标准。我最近其实在做一项培训，有人说，听着，我正在努力让生活更有平衡感，我只想做一份合格的工作。我问我的经理，我能只做一份合格的工作，而不是追求超出预期吗？
But then their comp, their comp was, like, there's ties to their comp and their bonus structure that if they don't exceed, they don't get anything. So if you just do a good enough job at your job, which we're always telling people who have perfectionism, like, it's focus on the good enough Like, if you just do good enough, you don't get additional compensation. So you have to constantly be exceeding to be able to reach certain comp norms. I do think there's a lot in our systems that really have to change so that we don't reinforce this. Don't burn people out and use them for what they have and then discard them. We have to be more thoughtful about the workers in our system and how we take care of them
但随后他们的薪酬与奖金结构挂钩，如果不超出预期，他们就什么也得不到。所以，如果你在工作中只做到足够好，而我们总是对有完美主义倾向的人说，要专注在“足够好”这一点上——如果你只是做得足够好，你是拿不到额外报酬的。因此，你必须不断超越，才能达到某些薪酬标准。我确实认为我们的系统里有很多东西真的必须改变，这样我们才不会强化这种现象。不要把人们燃尽，榨干他们的价值然后丢弃他们。我们必须对系统中的员工以及如何照顾他们有更多的思考，
and how we create longevity for their careers. And I think there's a lot we can do around management and organizations to change these systems that are reinforcing it. you know, ordinarily. Yeah, no, absolutely. And the other sort of suggesting that I would make, and this is a more difficult one because it really speaks to culture,
以及如何为他们的职业生涯创造长久的发展。我认为围绕管理和组织，我们可以做很多事情来改变这些正在强化该现象的系统，通常来说。是的，没错，绝对是这样。我要提出的另一个建议，这是一个比较困难的建议，因为它确实关乎文化，
is creating an environment where it's okay to acknowledge that one has made a mistake, to acknowledge that one is not perfect. And this should come from the leaders, from the people, the managers. And this is a bit, imagine what it would be like for an employee
那就是创造一个环境，让人可以坦然承认自己犯了错，承认自己并不完美。这应该来自领导者、来自人们、来自经理们。这有点像，想象一下员工会有什么感受，
to have a manager to sort of say, you know what, I messed up. I dropped the ball here. I made a mistake. And, you know, it's okay. We're human. Imagine the impact that that would have on employees when their managers acknowledge that sometimes they make mistakes as well. Now. Yeah, I'll take it one next one step further, which is like, and then do like a post-mortem on the mistake so everyone can learn from it. Exactly. You know? And have such more of a growth mindset perspective as opposed to a fixed mindset perspective about people's capacities and capabilities. Now, exactly. Now, we all know that changing culture is easier said than done. Culture tends to be among the most difficult things to sort of try to change.
如果有一个经理会说，你知道吗，我搞砸了。我在这里失误了。我犯了个错误。而且，没关系的。我们都是人。想象一下，当经理们承认他们有时也会犯错时，这对员工会产生怎样的影响。现在。是的，我会再往前推进一步，也就是对错误进行事后剖析，这样每个人都可以从中吸取教训。没错。你知道吗？与对人们能力的固定思维模式相比，更应该持有这种成长型思维模式的视角。没错。现在，我们都知道改变文化说起来容易做起来难。文化往往是最难试图改变的事情之一。
But if that could happen, it could go such a long ways. I mean, if companies are really serious about being responsive to the needs of their employees, this is one of the things that they absolutely should do. Yeah. The well-being of their employees are a lot of talk about well- being and mental health. And these, there are correlates to imposter syndrome to mental health outcomes, burnout, depression, anxiety. If you want to reduce that in your staff, reduce some of the ways in which you are organized to encourage them to do this, you know. Well, this has been really interesting. I think you've offered some good advice to people who may be experiencing the
但如果这能够发生，它将会产生深远的影响。我的意思是，如果公司真的认真对待员工的需求并做出回应，这绝对是他们应该做的事情之一。是的。员工的福祉——有很多关于福祉和心理健康的讨论。这些与冒名顶替综合征相关的心理健康结果包括职业倦怠、抑郁、焦虑。如果你想减少员工队伍中的这些现象，就要减少那些鼓励他们这样做的组织方式，你知道的。嗯，这真的很 interessant（有趣）。我想你为那些可能正在经历这种现象的人提供了一些很好的建议，
phenomenon. And certainly it doesn't appear that it has held you to back in any way in life. I think you've been quite successful and I've enjoyed spending some time with you. So thank you. Thank you. Likewise. I've enjoyed it too. It's been lovely. For our listeners, you can read more about imposter phenomenon in the June issue of APA's magazine Monitor on Psychology. Go to www.apa.org slash monitor or look for a link in our show notes. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology at speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you're so inclined, please leave us a review.
而且显然这并没有在任何方面阻碍你在生活中的发展。我认为你相当成功，而且我很享受和你在一起的时光。所以谢谢你。谢谢。彼此彼此。我也很享受。这很美好。对于我们的听众，你可以在美国心理学会（APA）杂志《心理学观察》（Monitor on Psychology）六月号上阅读更多关于冒名顶替现象的文章。请访问 www.apa.org/monitor 或在我们的节目文稿中寻找链接。你可以在 speakingofpsychology.org 或在苹果、Stitcher或你获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学之声》以前的节目。如果你愿意，请给我们留个评论。
If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. That's speaking of psychology, all one word, at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condihan. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你对未来的播客有任何评论或想法，请给我们发电子邮件：speakingofpsychology@apa.org。也就是 speaking of psychology，连在一起，在 apa.org。《心理学之声》由李·韦纳曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。我们的音频剪辑师是克里斯·康迪汉（Chris Condihan）。谢谢收听。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills），代表美国心理学会。本集尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。